لكن مشاهدينا وصل هذا الحديث عن نفاد
الوقت لتحجيم ايران نوويا خرجت هارت
بتقرير مفاده ان اجواء اذربيجان مفتوحه
لشني اي هجوم عسكري اسرائيليه على المنشات
النوويه الايرانيه الصحيفه كشفت عن ان
باكو تعهدت لتل ابيب باستخدام مطارات ادبي
جان في حال جون هجوم اسرائيلي محتمل ضد
مواقع ايران النوويه وذلك في اطار التعاون
العسكري بين اسرائيل
واذربيجان في تقريرها حقيقه ذكرت هارت ان
ما لا يقل عن اثنتين وتسعين طائره شحن
اذريه انطلقت من قاعده
للقوات الجويه الاسرائيليه وهي متوجهه
للعاصمه باكو كما انها محمله باطنان من
المعدات والاجهزه العسكريه التعاون بين
الدولتين فيما يتعلق بالملف النووي
الايراني ليس بجديد فوفقا لمصادر اجنبيه
سمحت اذربيجان لجهاز المخابرات
الاسرائيليه الخارجيه المساعد بفتح ممثليه
له في العاصمه باكو ايضا بنت اسرائيل
مطارا على الاراضي الاثريه ليتم استخدامها
حتى في حال شنت اسرائيل هجوما عسكريا
لتدمير البرنامج النووي الايراني صحيفه
اراد سبق لها ان اشارت الى ان الموساد
الاسرائيلي الذي استولى على وثائق من
الارشيف النووي الايرانيه عام 2018
نقل الوثائق عبر الشاحنتين الى اراضي
اذربيجان ومنها جوا الى اسرائيل
السؤال المطروح الان مشاهدينا ما مدى جدوى
استعمال اراضي اذربيجان في حال حدوث هجوم
اسرائيلي على منشات ايران النوويه اسرائيل
وضعت نصب عينيها كما تقول مصادر
استخباراتيه غربيه استهداف منشات تشمل
خمسه مفاعلات اساسيه نتابعها في هذه
الخريطه مو شهر اصفهانز اراك فوردو ومنشاه
تخزين المواد المشعه في كرج كما ايضا هناك
منشاه بارشين العسكريه بالاضافه الى
العديد من المطارات العسكريه ومنظومات
الدفاع الجوي التي ستشكل الخطر الاكبر على
الطيارين الاسرائيليين لكن قبل الوصول
توجد عده مسارات محتمله للمقاتلات
الاسرائيليه لضرب الاهداف الايرانيه منها
مثلا اختراق المجال الجوي العراقي وصولا
الى الاراضي الايرانيه او عبر الاجواء
السوريه التركيه وهما مسارى معقدان لماذا
لوجود ايرانيه في هذه المنطقه المسار
الاسلم لكنه الاطول مسافه سيكون بالالتفاف
من البحر الاحمر وصولا الى مضيق هرمز ومنه
الى الاراضي الايرانيه بالمقارنه مع كل
هذه المسارات السابقه يعتبر ضرب الاهداف
انطلاقا من اذربيجان الطريق الاقصر على
سبيل المثال مسافه الخط الجوي بين باكو
وطهران هو
537 كيلومترا فقط الهجوم الجوي عبر
اذربيجان سيلغي معضله تزود الطائرات
بالوقود في الجو او البحث عن قواعد تمكن
المقاتلات الهبوط فيها للتزود بالوقود
بانتفاء المشكله اللوجستيه تصبح اسرائيل
بحاجه الى قنابل امريكيه من طراز جي بي يو
28 هي قنبله ذكيه تزن اكثر من 2000
كيلوغرام يتم توجيهها باشعه الليزر وتملك
خاصيه النفاذ عميقا في داخل الارض لاختراق
التحصينات الايرانيه وبسبب
وزن هذه القنبله الكبيره لا تستطيع
الطائرات حمل اكثر من قنبله واحده ما
سيعني حاجه اسرائيل الى اسطول من الطائرات
المقاتله لتنفيذ الهجوم وطائرات اخرى
لمواجهه المضادات الارضيه وفتح الطريق
لتلك التي تحمل القنابل
[موسيقى]
الان سنتحدث عن الجانب السياسي فتصاعد
التوتر بين طهران وباكو في يونيو من العام
الماضي بعدما تحدثت السلطات الايرانيه عن
وجود عسكري اسرائيلي بالقرب من حدود
اذربيجان وايران هو امر نفته حكومه باكو
لاحقا قال وزير الخارجيه الايراني حسين
امير عبداللهيان ان العلاقات بين البلدين
عادت الى طبيعتها وما لبست العلاقات عن
عادت للتوتر بعد هجوم مسلح مميت على سفاره
اذربيجان في طهران ليعلن مساعد وزير
خارجيه اذربيجان في فبراير الماضي تعليق
النشاط الدبلوماسي للسفاره في ايران بشكل
كامل اليوم طالب المتحدث باسم وزاره
الخارجيه الايرانيه ناصر كنعان دول الجوار
بالانتباه الى ما اسماها حساسيات ايران في
علاقات هذه الدول مع اسرائيل
وشاركااني ايضا خلال مؤتمره الصحفي الى ان
اجراء تحقيق مفصل في الاعتداء على السفاره
الاذربيجانيه مطروح على جدول الاعمال